the best revenge is to not be like them
my version on Revenge is a little bit
more like the inability to even care
about their action to shrug it off okay
not only shrug it off it's almost as if
it didn't happen it like goes on this
nice little shelf I'm like that's nice
you can play with yourself in that
Cocoon of like whatever you feel about
me you've now become a energy that is
just like not a good use of time that's
how I've dealt with like people that
have done really not nice things and to
be frank I've evolved a little bit from
that deploying really deep sympathy the
thought at this point in my life that
you want to spend any of your time
hurting somebody else's feelings seems
outrageously foreign and really just
makes me feel compassionate